[ __ ] senior political analyst Brit Hume
joins us tonight but there's an awful
lot going on so I just want to go in
order through a couple of stories first
Tillerson what do you make of this well
it just showed that you cannot disagree
with the President on major foreign
policy issues to wit the Iran deal right
and last forever and there are other
differences as well and plus the fact
Tucker that the State Department can be
a pretty bulky place and this president
is nowhere near the first president has
had trouble getting his arms around it
and getting control of it there's a good
argument of whether Tillerson did either
over there but there's always this
question with secretaries of state are
they representing the State Department
to the White House or the White House to
the State Department and I think that
the feeling in this administration in
this White House was that Tillerson had
become to some extent at least a
creature of the building although he
wasn't thought over there to be all that
popular so his days were probably number
it's regrettable Tucker because it means
we'll have a period of delay while Mike
Pompeo gets installed and goes through
this arduous confirmation process the
same will be true for his deputy who's
not supposed to take over at CIA and
that leaves a period in which the
agencies are not functioning in the way
that their new leaders will want them to
and it's regrettable at this you know
still early stage of this administration
that they're still getting the right
people in place yeah it is regrettable
what do you make of the report the
Republican the majority report from the
Intel committee yesterday that found no
collusion between the Trump campaign and
Putin I think it's probably correct that
that that committee did find no
collusion and I would note Tucker this
is in the face of all the criticism that
that happened that house Intel committee
and its majority have received that
meanwhile over in the over in the
sainted Senate Intelligence Committee
its chairman Richard burr of North
Carolina Republican of North Carolina
said to a television interview in the
last day or so that that investigation
which has been thought to be very much
more sober and bipartisan and better had
come so far a sense of the same
conclusion and I think there's a good
reason for that there in all likelihood
there is there was no collusion
there's been no evidence of it so far
and I think that piece of their
conclusion is probably correct and I
noticed that even Adam Schiff of
California who's been a dog EDA Center
and one might say a very partisan one on
that House Committee even he and
announcing the conclusions didn't all he
said was the investigation should
continue he may not say that he or that
committee has evidence that would that
would dispute there or even refute the
committee's conclusion on collusion it's
a good point he called it a tragic
milestone but didn't explain why and and
finally the special election in
Pennsylvania tonight a district outside
Pittsburgh the president won by 20
points seems very tight tonight what
does this mean are we inflating its
meaning undervaluing it what do you
think well it's such an odd election
Tucker that I would hesitate to draw
major conclusions from it certainly the
closeness of the race is a sign of the
the force of the protest vote that will
come out to vote for the Democrat
because of mr. Trump I don't like as
much question about that in addition
they have this young and rather
attractive candidate on the Democratic
side and a somewhat dowdy character on
the Republican side and this is also
conducted to some extent in the shadow
of the departure of the previous
Republican incumbent who left him in a
sex scandal yet always cast a pall over
his party's nominee and the in this in a
special election of this kind of a bear
in mind that this is an election to fill
a seat between now and basically next
November and which there'll be a whole
new district because of redistricting
and this district will go away so
legislatively it's pretty insignificant
but it will be seen as a bellwether on
both sides depending on who wins no
doubt about it it's interesting that the
Democrat is running away from the gun
issue which I think a lot of Democrats
think is a winner for them but not this
one apparently oh oh yeah he certainly
is and you know and and he's saying you
know he won't back Nancy Pelosi for
speaker he's trying to convince the
people in that district law it's a
majority democratic district it's been
it's been hospitable to Republicans for
a long time now and it's sort of I've
been considered a safe red district he
hasn't run away from the mark from the
from the party on everything I gather he
doesn't that did not support the tax cut
which I think you know the benefits of
which may be starting to be felt in that
in that
than the district so we'll see what
effect that has but there's a lot of
cross currents here Tucker it's an
unusual race britt hume the voice of
reason in a turbulent world Thank You
Brett thanks Tucker